VO: This episode of Fun Science is brought to
you by Skillshare.
CHARLIE: [YELP!]
You frightened the life out of me!
What on earth are you doing up so late?
Looks like you might need a lesson in the
importance of a good night's sleep,
in this episode of...
[FUN SCIENCE THEME SONG]
If you're lucky enough to live until you're
90, chances are you would have spent about
30 years of your life asleep, which is crazy
when you consider that scientists are still
yet to agree on exactly why our bodies tempt
us into bed every night.
What we do know about sleep however, is just
how important it really is.
VO: Now it used to be thought that when you went
to sleep your body just sort of...
turned off.
MIKE: Goodnight.
VO: But of course, if our bodies did just turn
off like this, we'd all be quite dead.
What we know now is that it's more like your
body gets dialed down.
Our breathing slows, our heart rate lowers
and the muscles in our body relax.
We even experience a decrease in body temperature.
CHARLIE: This is when we enter the stage of sleep known as slow wave, or deep sleep,
during which our bodies do some amazing things like repairing themselves and releasing growth hormones,
all of which is essential for our health.
MIKE: [SNORE]
In fact, some studies have shown that sleep
is as essential to our health as food,
with sleep deprivation being as dangerous as starvation.
VO: Obviously this is bad news for those of us
who suffer from sleeping difficulties, though
fortunately if you do have trouble getting
a good night's sleep, cognitive behavioral
therapy, or CBT, might help as it's been shown to reduce these issues by 50% on average.
CHARLIE: So, we know how important sleep is for our
bodies, but how about our brains?
VO: Well, when we sleep, it gives our brains time
to take stock of all the stimuli we've been
subjected to throughout the day.
MIKE: The name of the cute barista that smiled at
you today...
GONE!
VO: With a healthy 7 to 8 hours each night, our
mind can sort through all this information
committing the useful stuff to memory and
chucking the bits we don't need.
MIKE: The humiliating feeling you got when you accidentally misgendered one of your co-workers...
we're going to hold on to this one forever!
CHARLIE: After slow wave you enter the deepest part
of the sleep cycle known as Rapid Eye Movement
or REM sleep, during which our brains actually
show as much activity as when we're awake.
VO: REM sleep is also when we have some of our
most vivid dreams.
Why we dream is still a mystery to science
but what we do know is that this is also when
we enter sleep paralysis, which stops us from
moving our bodies, thus helping prevent us
from acting out our dreams in real life.
CHARLIE: Man, all this talk about sleeping has made
me feel very...
[YAWN]
Did I make you yawn?
You it used to be thought that yawning was
a way of bringing more oxygen into the body
at times when our breathing had slowed.
VO: But now research is suggesting that as we
get more tired the temperature regulations
of our brain don't function as efficiently,
and so to combat this our body forces us to
bring in a deep breath of nice, cool air.
[YAWN]
One theory behind why yawns are contagious
is that, based on evolution, it would make
sense for groups to be able to coordinate
times of activity and rest.
CHARLIE: [YAWN]
MIKE: [YAWN]
CHARLIE: So, next time you're up past your bedtime,
don't forget just how important a good night's
sleep is for your body and your brain.
Sleep tight!
Though, if you do have trouble sleeping, did
you know that there's a Skillshare course
for that?
VO: In fact, as well as courses like this one
on how to get a better night's sleep, Skillshare,
which is an online learning community, has
loads of other courses to check out on topics
like lifestyle and creativity.
And if you're one of the first 500 people
who sign up using the link in the description
you'll get your first two months for free,
giving you access to all the courses on Skillshare.
So, go and learn, or go and sleep, and thanks
for watching!
Bye bye.